it's almost here the new 10-part
original series with Candace convicting
a murderers coming to daily wire plus
next week very excited about this series
you'll see the shocking amount of
evidence that was omitted in making a
murderer don't take my word for it watch
the series yourself draw your own
conclusions here's the trailer
Netflix made millions of dollars from
making a murderer but the filmmakers
left out very important details I don't
know if I'm a suspect I've been on a
high
daily wire viewers get exclusive Early
Access on September 7th to view episodes
one and two of convicting a murderer the
series makes its official debut on X
once known as Twitter on September 8th
at 9 Eastern Candace will also be
hosting a live event on X at 5 PM
Eastern with some special guests stay
tuned for that the full series will only
be available on Delaware plus so go to
dailywire.com subscribe to get access to
watch the full series as new episodes
are released every Thursday daily wire
plus.com slash subscribe